is an actual serial killer uh this Ohio
woman who was just charged in connection
to the deaths of at least four men that
she had met for sex this according to
the cops here it could be more men her
name is Rebecca Auborn she's only 33
years old clearly lived a little bit of
a hard life if you look at her mug shot
uh She's accused of robbing and fatally
drugging victims in January a 2 in April
1 in June according to a joint statement
from the Attorney General of Ohio and
the Columbus Police Chief and here is
what the AG said AG said don't buy sex
in Ohio it ruins lives and could cost
yours obviously true so the woman was a
hooker I guess and these Sad Sack men
were paying her for sex and they wind up
getting killed for their
trouble which underscores a point that
I've made for some years
now
against legalizing or decriminalizing
sex work against the hookup culture
against swipe right
culture it is better to sleep with
people you
know and it is even better to sleep with
people you like and it is best of all to
sleep with your
spouse and that I guess it's
controversial today that in fact that is
controversial if if if I were running
for office and I said hey I I used the
nor McDonald line I said hey sex is
obviously a filthy shameful thing that's
only meant for procreation and you
should only do it with your wife if I
came out and said that the Jens sakis of
the world the the liberal commentators
the Democrat politicians they would
laugh at me they would call me crazy
they would mock me they would pretend
that my view was totally French that is
the view that has been held by most
people in most civilized places on Earth
for all of human
history and it's been mocked in recent
years and then even the Attorney General
of Ohio then even some of the liberal
media if they report on that story
they're going to have to admit it's true
it's the what rard Kipling called the
gods of the copy book headings the the
the knowledge that we've all had for so
many years that the radicals in the
revolutionaries over throw and they say
our ancestors our grandparents and all
the people before them they they were
just dumb idiots they didn't know
anything we we've invented the world a
new it's all different now and men can
be women and babies don't have to be
babies and all the old rules no longer
apply but they do the rules keep coming
back because it's not up to you it's up
to reality okay and the more that you
twist your political ideology away from
those sometimes inconvenient sometimes
undesired fact acts of reality the more
likely you will be to find yourself a
victim a victim of political chaos or in
this case a victim of a serial killing
psycho hooker right now go to Ruff
greens.com
naturopathic do Dennis black the founder
of Ruff greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America dog
food may as well be considered dead food
since it contains very little
nutritional value let Ruff greens bring
your dogs food back to life Ruff greens
is a supplement that contains all the
necess vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just need to sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic
doctor Dennis black is so confident that
rough greens will improve your dog's
health he is offering my listener a free
jump start trial bag so your dog can try
it get a free jump start trial bag
delivered straight to your door in just
a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com or call 844
rf123 that is rfffg greens.com or call
844 ruff1 123
today there is a new number two
candidate
in Iowa for the Republican Party and
that would be Nikki Haley who in the
picture on the screen is wearing a
sweater that I own it's one of my
favorite sweaters it's that cool Ralph
Lauren flag sweater and Nikki Haley also
looks good sounds good is basically
inoffensive she doesn't fire up the base
necessarily
but she is firing up a portion of the
GOP that desires some kind of return to
normal and this is really bad news for
disantis because DeSantis was the number
two guy in Iowa Trump still has a big
lead but the disantis campaign was
doubling down moving a lot of their
campaign staff and resources to Iowa and
so the news that Nikki Haley is now tied
with him in Iowa is not going to be
welcome why is it why is DeSantis
failing to catch fire I really like
Ronda Sanz I think he's a good guy
personally I think he was a great
Governor I think he'd make a good
president why is he not catching on
because you know I hate to say I told
you so but it's because of what I've
observed as to santis is Challenge from
the beginning which is that his
candidacy was pitched as Donald Trump
without the baggage and Trump without
the baggage only works if Trump is not
in the race because if Trump is in the
race people are going to want the
original even if New Coke tastes better
than old Coke people want the OG they
want the Coca-Cola classic so for the
people who like Trump and they like the
ways in which Trump changed the GOP and
in in my view returned the GOP to
something much more traditional much
more in with its own history but if you
kind of like that and even if you think
that Trump he tweets too much he says
crazy things he
whatever you're still probably going to
be with Trump maybe some people will
spin-off but you still you're still
probably going to stick with
Trump and if you don't like Trump then
you're going to hate Trump without the
baggage because Trump without the
baggage the the pitch at least is that
it's just a more effective version of
trump with all the same priorities and
with the same potential achievements
maybe even more achievements in that
direction which you don't like because
you are opposed to Trump you were
opposed to the ways in which Trump
changed the Republican party so where
does that leave you the pitch of it was
Ronda santis is the best of all worlds
and I I think the guy would be
terrific but the reality on the ground
as some of us predicted and is is is
being borne out in the polls now not
just with Trump's numbers but with the
other candidates numbers is that it
leaves you with without a
constituency because your natural base
is going to your Chief
opponent and the people to whom you're
trying to also appeal so you get a
little bit broader slice of the
electorate is going to go to someone who
is totally
distinct from the front runner so it
leaves you now in second place but who
knows how much longer and Nikki Haley
who many people were calling to drop out
of the race early on because they said
she doesn't have a snowballs chance in
hell she's out of touch with the current
GOP base I always thought she might have
a bit of a shot because she's offering
an alternative she's offering a distinct
view to Trump which could which could at
least have some Runway man that was a
great clip huh now hey hey hey
stop ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls podcast we'll see you next
time